well guys I made a video recently called
why gaming needs help and I got some
really great feedback on that but one of
the things that I definitely made clear
was that I was gonna be buying some of
these newer systems eventually and I did
very soon in fact I recently just bought
my Wii U I played Super Mario 3d World
that was the game that finally got me to
buy it because I had been wanting to
test it out I love Nintendo products I
think they make great games when they
really really focus on these games they
can make some incredibly fun stuff and I
wanted to see what this game was like
I've always been a Mario fan I've always
been a Nintendo fan so here's my review
of Super Mario 3d World Number it comes
to Mario games the plot has never really
been that important I mean it's pretty
much always the same thing Mario's
friends are in some sort of danger and
he's got to figure out a way to go
through various worlds to try to beat
Bowser and save his friends and whenever
a Mario game tried to get too heavy with
plot it didn't always really work out as
well and it wasn't as fun as others
where Mario games have always excelled
is inventive controls clever level
design and really challenging obstacles
and this game really has that going for
it it's really such a joy to play a game
that knows exactly what it is it never
tries to go beyond that or become
anything more than it should be it knows
100% what it is cuz various touch
options in the game where you can touch
the screen to create new blocks to form
that you can jump cross and just doing
that seemed extremely fun for some
reason it was just cuz like bling bling
bling like it just felt right the timing
for everything just felt exactly right
and you could tell that these guys went
through this game hundreds and hundreds
of time to try to make the timing just
perfect for all these little things you
have to do so it all fits into place and
it just felt like butter when you slice
a knife through butter and it just feels
smooth and that's the way if I'm just
grabbing Mario with butter I see another
thing that I really liked about Super
Mario 3d World was the fact that the
level select designs was a complete
nostalgia trip for me they were exactly
like Super Mario Brothers 3 for the NES
and Super Mario World for the Super NES
you know where you go from little
building to building and then a little
line creates as you continue to beat the
various levels I was like oh it's just
like the old days it was great I loved
it it felt just like I was playing a new
modernized version of the older games
and that's kinda what they were going
for I think they were like we don't care
about cutscenes and plot points and all
these various things we're just going to
create a Mario game where you are Mario
and you can go and do whatever you want
in these lands that are clever and fun
it brings back the time element where
the time is counting down that brought
my heart rate up at a few times one of
the coolest features about this game
though is definitely the Wii U gamepad
and this is one of the main reasons that
I didn't buy a Wii U at first because it
just looks like a Sega Game Gear like
you're just holding this giant thing and
you're like Ruth is fun but this is
mungus I found myself really enjoying it
it just feels extremely comfortable in
your hands it feels like it fits the
other thing I like about this game is
that it supports off-tv play so I can
actually turn off my TV and play on this
thing and I cannot tell you how
surprised it was I actually want a full
floor below where my system wants
downstairs in the living room and I'm
able to play this game down there that's
how far the signal reaches and I was
extremely impressed by that the music is
also great also I'm not in my room right
now I'm actually in my office I am full
signal it's awesome but there are so
many really cool features to this game
like you can actually blow on the Wii U
gamepad and some enemies will blow away
it's crazy it's awesome there's various
new features too like cat marner that
are a lot of fun you can crawl up walls
splitting into multiple Mario's that was
really cool too and there were certain
little inventive things like that that
seems so simple when you think about it
when you're actually doing it in the
game it's just so much fun you just feel
like kid again the one thing I can't
really comment that much on is the
multiplayer because I haven't got too
much of a chance to use that we only
have the one gamepad right now we don't
have any other things to use multiplayer
with I heard that it's pretty cool
though I haven't got a chance to play
that so I apologize I can't really say
much about that it's actually funny
because after I beat the final stage
with Bowser I started to write my notes
for the review and I was like this game
is too short and I wrote that in my
notes I've been playing the game even
more so because there are a lot more
things to do after you beat the final
stage and the end credits play I was
very surprised by that it actually
almost felt like the actual game started
after the credits I'm not even kidding
because up until then I felt this is
really easy and a little too simple one
of the things though that I am very
happy with is that it's not maddeningly
hard there are a few levels at the very
end of Super Mario Galaxy where you had
to collect these purple coins where I
was literally punching the couch I
remember
I was punching the couch I hated it but
I beat it I got all under 20 stars this
game isn't that hard it's not like you
want to die as you played certain levels
in this game there are a few challenging
ones for the most part it's a fairly
simple and fun game to play really in
all honesty I think this game warrants
the purchase of a Wii you don't expect
Metal Gear Solid a series that I love
this isn't going to be a dramatically
heavy and deep weighty game it's going
to be an extremely fun game that you can
play and feel like a kid when you do it
and I think that that is a reason to
check out the Wii U I think it's worth
your time guys I'm gonna give this game
a nine point five out of ten so guys
what's your favorite Mario related game
there's quite a bit of him now because
you know it is Mario what ha hmm I won't
do that ever again guys as always thanks
very much for watching and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck my nice